did you see what rogan posted mm-hmm you
know how he went you know he's getting
shipped
i love that he's doing this people give
him [ __ ] you know the spotify thing and
all this
and they're trying to cancel him go to
what he posted first of all this guy's
hilarious
instagram uh pretty sure it's instagram
it's a video maybe
keep going maybe he took it down oh
watch the video
by the way look at that face you know
what maybe it's twitter twitter
have to be twitter probably twitter
hello twitterworld hello twitter world
um it's about the spotify
oh there it is it's so [ __ ] yup
so just so pause it for a second so
spotify
has a group within their uh
place of business that want to cancel
rogan they want to censor rogan's shows
that's the lgbqt community it's probably
like 300 people missed them
but they wanna
when you're looking how big that that uh
business is it's a small percentage
okay but they're upset and they want to
censor joe rogan's podcast but they're
loud
they're the loudest on social media so
everyone's like oh my god everyone wants
to cancel
joe rogan no not everyone's canceled joe
rogan the companies
went from abil when they signed him it
hit a billion now they're worth 1.6
billion
so they're not gonna so whatever they do
they're not gonna let go of joe rogan
but they're the they're the minority but
they're very loud
and people think it's a bigger deal than
it is so it's all over right now oh so
this guy i don't think he's comedian
yeah he is he's [ __ ] that redhead
dude
is he yeah he is he's funny he tours us
he's great
watch this as spotify employees we're
demanding the executives
edit this buddy i know something i can't
keep my eyes off
walking out
wait
[Applause]
i was just about to say that you stupid
it's about how he likes trans people
which means he doesn't love trans people
which means he hates trans people this
is
so spot-on built a massive audience
because people enjoy and respect what he
and his guests have to say
but who knows better than his audience
what they want to hear we do
oh is that guy i think that's brent
pillow here but luckily here in the sjw
yeah yeah for them because we're highly
intelligent people
well kind of i identify as a cat but the
executives
cater to our demands it's almost like
they value 100 million dollar
asset more than a 49 000 asset these
high-level business executives just
don't know how to do business
i mean do a lot of people listen to joe
rogan's podcast yes
but would even more people listen to a
heavily censored version of that same
podcast
heavily censored version me also yes joe
logan cannot be broadcast talking about
the following
trans issues
[Laughter]
he doesn't want to have sex with men
which makes him homophobic
racial issues because he's always having
his black friends on his show and giving
them massive publicity and help for
their careers which he only does because
he's white
and he feels guilty about being white as
he should
this most real video on youtube wow
that's so
funny i'm a vegan dmt because it's a
drug and i only take
adderall to people who can't think
comedy because it's hateful to people
who aren't funny
how caitlyn jenner killed somebody with
their car because i don't want to
believe that it's true
having open-minded conversations and
exploring new ideas
that's very dangerous and super
close-minded it's not how you learn
it's like the old wisdom that says
letting the inmates
run the asylum is always a good idea are
you listening to me spotify executives
i have to use my litter box now
the only reason he hunts elk is because
he thinks elk are actually trans women
which makes him hateful joe rogan is
yeah i appreciate you asking
i actually shut the whole what the hell
i missed
so i got mad at the refs for pushing an
oppressive narrative look how that pinky
is just so straight
so i quit because i couldn't stand being
around illogical referees who were
pushing a false narrative and oppressing
people that they had control over
because they had a whistle they were
ruining the game of basketball so anyway
if i don't get my way here at spotify
i'm walking out
[Music]
the executives refused to clean his
litter box
joe rogan stepped and pooped it in my
foot we have to stop this
monster in joe rogan's own words that
i'm putting into his mouth
he hates all people who don't have
kettlebell calluses on their head
kettlebell callus childish pressure on
the spot
watch this they have an outtake of him
going censor joe rogan
then we'll be happy to work towards
censoring your music and then burning
your books
because with spotify employees not only
do we know what's best
but we also care wow
or we are walking out
[Laughter]
one more thing you weird stop it okay i
forget his name though
that's how you deal with haters how
great is that great yeah yeah
that's so great so spotlight it is it's
wild man how you deal with haters
i mean i mean if i hate something i just
don't pay attention to it
well that's a little different than
haters because the these these people
are you know they're loud and they they
don't like what
rogan represents you know does he
represent
men men like you know successful
alpha males you know they think that
they don't want to give them a platform
so they they think by censoring his
podcast
is the way to do it and they're going to
walk out if spotify doesn't do it
you know what spotify is going to say
what there's the door
wow yeah they're not going to you just
can't
jp sears there you go jp thank you that
was going to bug me fine there's another
really funny video about uh
la how terrible it is to live in l.a but
he acts like it's all good
it's so funny that's hilarious he's
crashing it man yeah
no he's he's good dude but he was spot
[ __ ] on with that man
man i didn't know it was like that damn
how do you guys
not see it how do you i mean that's not
even on you that's not even world star
that's just
general man the first thing i do when i
wake up is read a book oh
what else and then i journey keep going
no
you see no news no like the debates
nothing no i saw the debates that [ __ ]
was funny
about sports of course you got to watch
for first year
no because i don't i don't have the you
got i got to pay extra if i want to
watch
damn uh sports you know why are you
how are you what is this well because
i'm pointing at my tv because my tv is
above
oh and i'm thinking something shout out
to mountains
streaming services what do you have i
have hulu i have youtube
comments modifying netflix netflix come
on that's my girls netflix say let's uh
other ones are mine uh what else i got
don't you hate when you have you know on
somebody else's netflix account and they
don't pay their bill you're like yo
oh my
[Applause]
cut that out where you can't share
accounts anymore they're like they're
shutting you can't wait wait i mean
they're they're making it tougher to
share it though there's like a limit now
mm-hmm
oh so you know they're trying to make it
like it's a game you got to feeling it
once you get in you got to die out i
don't like that yeah no
no netflix relax relax relax no but yeah
yeah i mean you don't see the news huh
mm-hmm
when i get off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just run a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song